how are you doing today sir
i'm great it's wonderful to see you it
always gives me memories back to uh when
i first started so i i'm proud of seeing
your accomplishments and uh
i'm honored to still be in the game um
yes i'm also happy to still be in the
game uh
uh so during the pandemic i've been
asking everyone the same first two
questions
uh and here here we go um what tv series
would you love to guest direct
oh sopranos got it
cool um what movie or movies do you
think you've seen the most
uh specifically which films i would say
rocky i've seen i mean fletch rocky
um dog day afternoon
uh a prophet i don't know i all i do is
watch movies
on and on and on uh i don't know i just
watch everything
so um jumping backwards for a second as
you know i was open
and i guess too sorry i don't know why i
threw that one in there i think i think
that pulp fiction for
i don't know anyone who hasn't seen pulp
fiction multiple times
it's one of those it's a fun one daisy
confused
um i don't know there's so many movies i
could talk about days and confused for
the next hour
um so i want to jump backwards as you
know i i was a
big fan of lincoln lawyer and i i've and
i think maybe we've talked about this i
don't remember
how close did you guys ever get to doing
a sequel or developing a sequel
we were really close actually there were
two things going on
simultaneously there was a tv show that
was going to happen in abc
and then there was the sequel which was
going to be an amalgamation of two books
um and unfortunately as it goes due to
rights and relationships and a lot of
different things
uh tom rosenberg and gary lucas at
lakeshore
part ways of michael conley and that was
sort of the beginning of the end
and uh i think financially
movies are more lucrative for book
writers than
television shows so mike was always
leaned into trying to figure it out but
he ended up in the hands of david kelly
and it went to cbs
and then subsequently now it's at
netflix and um
i'm not involved in that yeah i was i
was always wondering
it's uh i was always wondering what
happened um
uh jumping into why i actually get to
talk to you today uh
so let's just start with the basics like
a softball right at the beginning
uh who killed tupac
uh that one i i have my theories i don't
actually know
that that one is so complicated so much
more as complicated as christopher
wallace's murder is
the murder of tupac is is so much more
complicated
um so that one's really tricky that i
don't really have a proper answer to and
i wish i did
and uh you know i i don't actually know
the answer to that but i have
multiple theories that on one day i
think x and the next day i think why but
i did have
on our movie there was a whole tupac
section
and we had an exact replica of the bmw
to a t
that him and sugar were in when he was
shot and
that car was in my possession for six
months
so i drove it and when you see how small
the interior of the car
is it's really hard to buy that suge
knight
called a hit on tupac in the same car he
was on
in that that that to me is a is a
for a moment i believed in that theory
just because of all the christopher
wallace stuff
i'm sure there are levels of
plausibility to that theory but when you
actually sit in the car
it's hard to believe it's also hard to
believe when you sit in that car that
shook didn't take any bullets at all um
and he lied about it too so i i i that
stuff is so
so tricky and so deep that um i truly as
i stated i just don't have a proper
answer
to it i mean i i could be wrong but i
read that uh that he
got fragments or something like so
you're saying that
that was all part of what i'm referring
to as the lie
right so you're saying he got hit he
never got hit
that's interesting he didn't he put it
in the news
in my understanding again i i have to
look back at this stuff it's been years
um but i'm pretty pretty sure that um he
had got a
bullet across the like scathing or
something like that but
to to my knowledge of police reports and
other things i've seen i don't think he
was
hit at all by the way i'm softball
i was i was messing with you i was just
like oh my god yeah
i was just completely messing with you i
i do want to talk about the fact that
um for younger people that are not
familiar with the 90s and what
happened then the killing of
christopher and tupac was the biggest
thing
for many years at that time i mean it
shook everything and it was what
everyone talked about can and can you
sort of for people that
weren't you know paying attention back
then for younger people can you sort of
explain that
samia was rjfk in a way um
tupac for me in particular had a
tremendous impact on me
from his music to the imagery to his
poetry to
um his social and political outreach and
affini shakur his mother being a black
panther and him being raised with
all of the sort of form formal political
understanding that i think a lot of
people were not as educated as poc
so it took his rap into a different
place
um biggie was just such a special
lyricist and these guys were just
on like rocket ship trajectories they
were larger than life i mean they
they were beyond being icons they really
were larger than life so to have both of
these young black men struck down and
have
lost their lives at such a young age is
quite devastating and it was a shock to
the world
um these were international as i'm
saying mega stars
plus and the fact that i think quincy
jones i i won't
nail it but he talked about at 25
if um malcolm x had died he would have
been known as detroit red
a street hustler um if oprah winfrey had
died she would have 25 she would have
just been known as a local news reporter
and i think his overall point was the
loss of pock in particular and obviously
let's equate that to biggie of these
young men black men
at such a young age it's it's a quarter
of their life potential if that
so if you can think about what
contextualize what they've achieved
in the limited time they were here which
is just
unbelievable then you can only imagine
what they could have become and
accomplished and achieved throughout
their lifetime which was cut so severely
short
how did you get involved in city allies
in terms of
how did it land on your desk and was
there ever any apprehension
at taking on this material came
across my desk right when the book was
published uh don sikorski an executive
producer on the film
produced the infiltrator and given me
the infiltrator book
brought the book to me right away due to
the stature of where i was at
in my career and financial limitations
and all of these things
and also i think it was optioned by two
studios and three movie stars
we were never able to get it made um i
believe will smith's company may have
had it
um i'm pretty sure an appian wayan
dicaprio's company had it
and maybe stallone's you can verify all
that stuff but
it had been around hollywood as the
bottom line and the reality is
i couldn't get my hands on it and
ultimately what ended up happening was
while i was making the infiltrator it
had come up
and don had come to me and said look i
think we can get labyrinth
i i jumped at the opportunity because
the expose to tell the modern day jfk
story with these two
iconic individuals and rappers who had
such a deep influence on me i i felt was
you know really a deep responsibility
incredibly important
and that's how i attempted to approach
it it wasn't as simple of a story as
that but i won't bore you with the long
version of the ins and outs of how it
evolved but essentially that's where it
started this is one of those
the story that you are taking on with
this film
is something that has fascinated so many
people and i would imagine
that you did an awful lot of research to
try to get your head around this entire
thing before
you know filming frame one so can you
sort of talk about a little bit
maybe what surprised you to learn or
like some of the things you
learned i guess while researching that
you really
i guess i just butchered the way i said
this but what surprised you during the
research process
in terms and any what what maybe shocked
you
then the first thing was and
so we get the rights to the book and at
the time the screenplay was actually
gifted to me which is part of that
longer story so it had been developed
into a screenplay
regardless of where that screenplay was
at i felt a deep responsibility to
surely reread the book from cover to
cover that book was a little over a
decade old at that point
so then the responsibility was even
deeper from my point of view which was
like well
it's been 10 years so then i started
going on to the internet and started
getting my hands on
anything and everything which was within
my reach and what i started to notice
was
not only was russell poole's theory at
that time particularly treated as if it
was
outdated or even false what was even
more insane was that
pretty much anyone could go on the
internet
or could write a book if you had some
connection to it and profit
and put a theory into the world and all
of a sudden that became
the theory and they were baseless most
of what i was finding was people
profiteering off this man's
death and murder and they were baseless
and the more and more research i did the
more and more it affirmed that the work
that russ poole had done
was beyond accurate and factual so i was
like
this is insane that this is not the
prominent theory on what's going on
so that then led me to perry sanders who
was the
attorney for valletta wallace and the
family um
in the civil civil case that also led me
to sergio robledo
who was the lead investigator for the
family for the civil case
but also happened to be russ poole's
supervisor for a large part of his
tenure at the lapd
it also led me up to portland i traveled
all over uh to randall sullivan
who was the author of the book and i
basically worked with sergio
um sergio has sadly passed and he was
such a warm wonderful inspiring human
being i could have never made this move
without him
i would not speak of this if he hadn't
have passed
but he gave me full-blown access to the
redacted files to depositions
i had my hands on everything so as a
result of that i had a really
insider's point of view and my own
reinvestigation of the case
into you know being able to analyze rust
pulse theory
and then go beyond that theory so it was
a pretty extensive um
journey to say the least i i never in
any movie have i ever
you know dove into had i ever dealt with
anything of this
magnitude and you know obviously i went
back and looked at oliver stone's jfk
but i truly did feel that this was a
version of i'm not saying as a film you
know that's
obviously quite a special film um you
know we set out to tell our story
and to tell the story um to fight for
truth and justice and
that's why i reached out to miss wallace
and asked her to be a part of the film i
couldn't make the film without her or
the poor family i wasn't willing to
talk a little bit about her involvement
in this thing was she apprehensive at
all or was it an immediate
once she understood that you were being
um you were really trying to get to the
bottom of this
we didn't know one another at all uh
through sergio robledo
and some other things i was able to get
her number i cold called her
i was very nervous and anxious because
in
movie land and in the land of these
icons
these people don't feel real to the
audience and what we're dealing with is
a real man
which is why i do this in the movie and
also in the world
named christopher wallace who was
murdered at the hands of the police and
there's a tremendous corruption
in the cover-up so this is a mother i'm
calling of a son
you know has a son who's been murdered
and i that to me the gravity of that was
never lost on me
and that's why i was unwilling to make
the film without her blessing
and that's why i also wanted to make it
hand in hand with her
but in seeing typical biopics what
typically happens and this is not a
biopic
but you cast actors to portray
these larger-than-life figures and i
didn't want to do that because i didn't
feel there was anybody
who could capture the charisma of a
biggie or a pop
or do any of that so i really worked
very hard
to humanize both of these men and that's
sort of the mother-son
you know thing that we're creating so
that's why when you're hearing
christopher's voice in the movie
it's a real conversation he had that's
why i embedded his
acapellas which miss wallace had gifted
me with wayne barrow
you know biggie's former manager into
the score that's why
all of the media you're seeing is real
and truthful all the pictures are real
and truthful
and in the one reenactment so to speak
i did cast the actor um that had
portrayed biggie but i really tried to
create
for 90 of it this impressionistic feel
of what christopher wallace felt like
and tried to in the few shots of his
face tried to blur them or keep them at
a
quite a large distance just to stick
with
the the truth of this human being that
we all
loved and appreciated that gave so many
gifts to the world
whose life was cut short and i could
have never done that
without wayne barrow biggie's former
manager and miss wallace
they they made the movie hand in hand
with us and i asked her
in person after nine months of a phone
trusted built relationship
would you i had asked her on the phone
and she laughed me off the phone and
said go get angela bassett she played
this role
i i'm not an actor but when i said to
her and i explained to her that
the gravity of having her in the film
and how that would humanize christopher
and humanize their plight and her fight
for truth and justice she was on board
uh yeah um and she's really good in the
movie
um and adds a lot the uh
i guess we should talk a little bit
about casting uh johnny and forrest
um uh what's interesting about johnny is
that
uh he tends to play roles where he's
under makeup
or doing things where you don't actually
see his face like that he he
strives to do those kind of movies all
the time and this is you know him
so talk a little bit about um getting
him in this movie
that was day one for me i i had a list
of um
requirements of what it would take for
me to commit to the film
um and you know in the international
sales game
of getting a movie star and triggering
your financing it's it's a game and
there's only a small list of actors on
that
that list and you have to nail one to
get your
you know movie financed i literally was
unwilling to make the movie with anyone
other than johnny depp
it was on my list of like this is the
only way i'm making movie
my reasoning for that was the gravity of
the story and my concern
deeply that in the wrong hands when i
had seen the list of actors that was
being suggested
i was very worried of like i don't like
of a boring version of russ poole and i
knew in the hands of johnny that it
would be something
unique and eccentric and um a little bit
off-centered and it's funny because
instinctually when we first started
diving into the character building
he wanted to play him with a bit of a
high-functioning
you know point of view we work to sort
of shed that down but there's like
bits and pieces of it that johnny
brought to the role but i really felt in
my heart
going back to donnie brosko and exactly
what you were saying
johnny's done this prosthetic work and
all this other stuff
and and it's brilliant and it's amazing
but i wanted to get him back to the
antithesis of that so
in a typical first meeting with an actor
you know
if you're trying to secure the actor
it's about you know if you're lucky an
hour hour and a half
uh my first meeting with johnny was
about nine nine and a half hours
and we it was it was it was super
wonderful and
really amazing but the elephant in the
room that i was stressed over was i was
unwilling to make the movie with him in
prosthetics
so i did bring that up in the meeting
and i got him at the end of the meeting
to say
maybe because we were shuttling between
you know 2015 and the past years earlier
his idea was to use the prosthetics in a
way
that you know he could do that and i
wanted to go for like raw
like 70s type filmmaking and like really
honest and truthful
and stripped johnny down in a really
human way and
that was very much in the dna of my goal
with him
so i was able to get the maybe from him
but
one of the things that i had to say to
him was like look i think you're
brilliant in black mass
but the prosthetics with the eyes were
really distracting for me
and it took me out and i thought took
away from your performance and i
it took some real i was afraid to say
that to him but i was losing the battle
of the prosthetics argument
so i had to pull out the card and his
response to me which was classic was
i wouldn't know i don't watch my movies
and
that was amazing you know he was so
committed to this film that he actually
watched this film and has been a
tremendous advocate for it i know he's
really proud of it and i'm really proud
that he's in the film and
um i couldn't ask for anything more from
him or and especially as an actor he's
been a real gem in the process to be
frank
uh what did you learn about you
obviously spoke to robert poole's family
uh what did you learn about him what did
you want to make sure got depicted in
the movie
um uh because he does seem like you know
in the film
he seems like someone really just
striving to get to the truth
no matter what i think russ's whole life
was embodied by that
um he has three children um in the
script that was originally given to me
it was amalgamated into one
um their their whole family
understood that russ's dedication to the
force
and russia's dedication to justice and
the truth was the embodiment
of the man and the character that he was
and uh
i think the family took a hit in a lot
of ways from
that level of dedication and commitment
that russ made and where things get
really exacerbated is
here's this guy trying to honor the
truth and do the right thing and follow
the conduct and code of what it really
means to him
to be a police officer the lineage of
that with his father also
in the force and basically he's being
pushed out of the force in disgrace to
this day
his family collects no money from the
pension benefits of him being a police
officer
so i think these things were really
taxing on him his weight was growing
i think he was drinking i think he was
going through a really really really
tough time and this stuff was incredibly
painful
the beautiful thing about the pool
family is they're really proud of
russ his integrity the father he was and
the husband he was
and they're really honored to have the
movie be made this was something that
russ
won it i was supposed to meet him two
weeks
uh when he passed away it was too our
date to meet was two weeks after his
passing sadly so we never actually got
to meet
and obviously as you could see the
gravity of all these things was gigantic
and i had a deep responsibility to the
poole family and the wallace family so
when the film was made and then
subsequently not coming out i was
relentless in my fight to
you know do everything i could in my
power and ability to get the movie out
because
i i gave them my word yeah um what
that's another thing what's it been like
waiting to get this thing you know so
people can actually see it
i wouldn't wish it on anyone who's a
filmmaker because you don't make movies
to then have no one
see them i remember we were having
conversations about potentially
bringing johnny and doing something at
the arclight and to me that was
would've been such a wonderful honor and
opportunity to share the movie
with the beginning stages of the world
and you know not only are we in a world
of covet
um and a pandemic but
this movie it's been in theory cursed
from day one i mean we've just been
riddled with insane problems
um i've had threats and warnings and
crazy people calling me and people from
the streets and people from the lapd
and i i we had a bankruptcy we had one
distributor who i thought you know we
had a perfect marriage with open road
and tom ortenberg being a wonderful
distributor of gravitas and spotlight
before us
and he was bullish on the finnish film
and all of these kind of things and
there was going to be more time to work
on it
um it was just an ideal situation to
have that go under and then end up with
global road and be treated like the
third stepchild and all their
nonsense that was going on and donald
tank's commitment to raise 400 million
and raise zero and then they go bankrupt
and then we're not in the bankruptcy but
we're a party to it legally so we're
trapped but we're not actually in the
bankruptcy so then when raven buys
everything out
we're still stuck and we're the only
movie that's stuck and i'm dealing with
an israeli bank that shut down their
whole finance division and
i mean it has been insane beyond
imagination
but i just kept sticking with it to the
best of my abilities because i
i believe that i think what's different
from me
about this film whether people like it
or hate it as with any film
i can't control but what i felt was
important was the messaging of the film
and with what has happened with social
justice and the world today
post when this movie was supposed to
come out
i went back and looked at the film
because i needed to and i was
really shocked by all of the things that
are now defined under the umbrella of
black lives matter and all the
injustices and
all the stuff with social justice and
you know the idea of the iconography of
this
uber famous guy black man being you know
murdered at the hands of the police and
this insane cover-up if it could happen
to biggie
if you're if you're a black individual
you feel it could happen to anyone if
his murder can be covered up so
there are messages and themes of
significance and important
in the film that i just feel are bigger
than me and
i've always felt that way i've mentioned
the word responsibility
almost too many times now and just
chatting and as a result
that's really what the film is about for
me um this was
a really arduous film in the production
process
the way it was handed to me and i'm very
very proud of it
very proud of all of the individuals who
worked on it but at the end of the day
it's also a very polarizing film
depending on where you are at
politically there's a card at the end of
the movie about 50
of african-american murders going
unsolved those were huge fights with
distributors to keep that card in
i mean those are political battles
beyond anything you could ever imagine
just to keep
a card in like that and that's a factual
card that was researched and
substantiated so
you know this has been a unique movie um
and hopefully
going to really demarcate for me a
change in trajectory of what i'm going
to be doing in my career
yeah the thing i rewatched the film
yesterday after having seen it
i mean maybe what two three years ago
yeah um you know forever ago
and it really when i saw it a while ago
um and seeing it again yesterday it did
strike me of how much the film talks
about
what's in the pop in in
society today which you couldn't have
known when you were making the film
was gonna be you know your your cup it
addresses
and talks about a lot of stuff that's
going on today it's also a shame that
these issues
have not gone away and that you know
it's a it's a constant
battle i agree with you and i appreciate
your recognition of it because uh
my intention wasn't to be ahead of the
curve i understand that change is
so challenging having made the
infiltrator with bob mazer he talks
about
you know he had all these arrests and
and did all these things but he feels
like he looks at the world and it had no
change or impact and it's devastating
for him
um and that's a hard thing because you
dedicate your life to something
hoping that there would be some change
and or impact and the reality
of this is you know i obviously have no
indication of any impact or change that
this will or won't have but i am
always trying to be positive and hopeful
and i am very much
honored to stand side by side with miss
wallace in her fight for truth and
justice and maybe this is the start of
that this is blown open
major doors to a podcast to a sequel
book for randall sullivan
to phil carson of the fbi speaking out
to potentially a documentary i mean this
has
opened a lot of doors to potentially
maybe a refiling of the civil case we'll
see
yeah it's interesting because just to be
clear the
the film talks about um how
david mack and kevin gaines and others
who were in the lapd
moonlighting for death row um and the
sort of
you know the way that they were
intertwined you know and
i it is interesting that you know it's
been what 24 years or 20 years
yeah 24 years and you know there's still
so much that the lapd will not talk
about
and you just have to wonder you know how
at what point will they just come out
and say
you know what i mean like where more
information is not going to be redacted
and they'll be willing to acknowledge
that maybe they had some officers that
shouldn't have been officers
yeah i i think that's the right thing to
do and uh it would give a lot of closure
to a lot of people
um but you know this is uh
as i was warned from many people early
on and a few people inside the lapd
they said brad you really don't
understand how much bigger than you this
is and how big and
you know it goes to the top that's what
they said and i
i'm still making the movie well yeah the
other thing though is and just being
honest
i i remember working at a movie theater
when i was in high school and there were
many police officers in that town
that would work overtime at the theater
you know like that's how they made money
and he and i remember
[ __ ] going down at that theater and you
know it never came out
you know it was just because the cops
were protecting um
you know like you know what i mean like
they didn't want to risk
bad publicity on the place that's paying
them you know double time or whatever it
is
you know yeah i i it's why i fought so
hard to get the kelly jamerson portion
into the story of the movie
i mean um that stuff is that's really
the first
time on record that there were often
off-duty lapd
officers you know working for death row
associated with the police at an event
where a man was
blatantly murdered in front of them and
it was on record and then later all
redacted i mean it was
that's was just super important to me to
take this hard-hitting approach
to you know the facts of the case
you're trying to tell a very real and
authentic story
but you're also making a movie so can
you sort of talk about showing that line
between fact and fiction and where you
are willing to embellish and where you
felt i need to this has to be as honest
as possible
it was a really really challenging thing
um
i didn't really embellish on anything
other than
things that i thought creatively were
like for example when i got the script
jack jackson was some amalgamation
i guess or version or incarnation i
should say of
uh randall sullivan but you know at this
point he was african-american and i
worked very tirelessly with forest
because i'm not a black man haven't
walked in those shoes
to try to represent and create
that character in a way that was very
honest and real
there's an issue with a particular piece
of evidence
regarding the car that you know jack
jackson brings in
i had to move the timeline on that but
it is an actual piece of evidence
um so it was a more amount about the
amalgam all the stuff with rafa perez
um was there but the way we had russ
poole
and him connect was different so i did
that i actually did the director's
commentary on purpose with randall
sullivan
because i wanted him to substantiate and
not be fearful of saying like
this didn't happen this way it actually
happened this way and i was very much
okay with that because when you listen
to not expecting you to but if
if someone listens to the director's
commentary with randall
you'll see that we're like right on the
line with things if we're changing it i
was really careful about these things
and
obviously um you know this stuff was
tricky also when i inherited the movie
uh you know the children were
amalgamated into one child versus the
three i mean there was just a lot of
little things but
you know i made the choice to honor and
live with many of the decisions
christian contreras made but in the same
breath
really focused on what i thought would
craft the movie from script to screen i
felt like it was a great read but it
didn't feel like when i first got at a
movie
so i had to figure out how to make it a
movie and um
you know that was a real challenge yeah
i don't think people are going to uh
um object to him having one kid in the
movie versus three yeah
i think that that's you know not as
important as depicting or getting
you know what i mean yeah no no i i
that's why i
um i didn't feel it would be responsible
to just fictionalize things for
dramatization
and not be able to substantiate them
with hard facts
and everything is factually based
in you know in theory in the movie and
if it's off by
having it been amalgamated or adjusted
that the facts behind it are
substantiated that's exactly why i
referenced the director's commentary
because randall i remember him sitting
with me
saying like that's not exactly what
happened with rafa perez and russ poole
but
this this this and this did happen with
rob for perez i see why you amalgamated
it
or the whole situation with the rampart
scandal you know
i mean the rampart scandal is like look
over here because all this is going on
and it's really a version of a scam
and you know we tried it you know
randall says in his book i spent 50
pages on this you spent one minute on it
you know so you see the difference so
yeah it's also
i mean listen that's the thing about um
making a movie versus a mini series
yeah you know uh this is a movie that
i'm sure
um could have benefited from a different
medium in certain ways it was obviously
much more unruly and bigger than i would
have ever imagined when i stepped into
it but
um i i purposely chose the
the the titans of depp and whitaker as
vessels to carry the message
i felt there was no better way to marry
commerce and art
and the marriage of marketing and the
significance in it in the distribution
of a movie
than to get these two heavyweights to
carry the message that was a very
conscious choice
yeah also there's so much that i'm sure
went on at death row records that has
never come out
you know so much and you know that's a
whole
thing on its own i mean if they ever had
the unedited
i mean i can't even imagine you know um
did you
talk a little bit about obviously you
didn't make this for some crazy budget
but did you have a
much longer cut i mean how what was your
director's cut versus the final
release it was probably about
45 minutes to an hour longer probably i
mean oh wow
maybe 45 minutes i would think 35 45
minutes i mean there was a version early
on that was an hour but
i i i whittled it down and whittled it
down it's a movie that's a super slow
burn
it's also odd for me how it really
impacts people
um some people are like super invested
in the relationship and the family
and are really moved at the end of the
movie other people don't care
um it's very polarizing in that regard i
found
um it's it's you can see it in the
reviews it's like
i mean i do think uh you know johnny's
been dealing with some publicly some
personal stuff that i think
unfortunately has had an impact on
perception of the film unfortunately as
well
which you know i don't think it should
we're dealing with the murder at the
hands of the police of one of the most
prominent black men
ever i don't think anybody's personal
life is going to usurp that
so dealing with that in my opinion is
inconsequential and ridiculous
to deal with anything regarding johnny's
personal life um regarding the the
seriousness of the subject matter um and
uh you know my my feeling overall is uh
you know i i i recognized that
in testing the movie and working with
open road and the movie they were
looking to release that there was just a
responsibility for such a slow burn
movie to whittle it down to as short as
possible because even then it feels
longer than it is um in certain ways
which it moves at times and it doesn't
and
you know we leaned into the information
it it's
it's it was just a conscious choice of
the film we were trying to make and what
i was trying to do
what were like the last scene or scenes
that you took out of the film like what
was the stuff that was right at the end
you're like
[ __ ] i don't know if i can lose this
scene for me
it was a few things number one i real
we had real problems um with
uh jack jackson's character and the way
the audience perceived him
um you know there's this i don't know
how much you want to get into this stuff
but with the nrg type testing
um and screen engine testing there's
these like
mediums of like what is standard that a
movie star should test and it was like
super odd that johnny was like
testing it through the roof and forest
was not and
i i looked at it what i had to choose to
do which was really cutthroat and
challenging
was i looked at it like jaws one of the
feedback
or a lot of the feedback we were getting
from audiences they didn't like the
woman he was dating they didn't like his
backstory they didn't like all the
negative things about him they didn't
understand how why he had this nicer
apartment and car they had all these
problems with him
so i took the jaws theory which was like
well i think the best thing that ever
happened to spielberg on jaws was the
shark dying
because then what's what we don't see is
much scarier than
what we do see so he really made that
work in the end
and that was the approach i really had
to take with jack jackson which was like
to cut out his backstory
so that when you meet him you just put
your own feelings and thoughts of who he
is on the character and his testing went
up like 20
and he started testing fairly high and
that was like
got you know open road really excited
and that was the move we had to make but
that was hard for me
and it was hard for forrest and um it
does turn his character in a way a
little bit more
into a vessel of facts and information
and and that stuff's challenging i mean
there's some incredible work and scenes
that he did
in his backstory that i i was always
riveted by this complex character who
had this
really challenged backstory and was a
much darker character
um we had scenes in the strip club with
the relationship with this particular
stripper who he was talking to the
about with the case and a big fight they
have and some wonderful stuff but
you know you know how movies go yeah i i
do
and uh that's why they invented blu-rays
and dvds for deleted scenes
i didn't put all the deleted scenes on
there but i i did put the fight because
i just thought forrest was so brilliant
and
uh natalie martinez was super brilliant
and um
you know i wanted to represent their
work i was careful about
you know um not careful that's not the
right word i was just
you know selective and making sure that
i gave the audience or the fans or
people who loved the movie or whatever
their feelings were an opportunity to
dig deeper
yeah i could i can actually understand
um
obviously i have not seen those those
scenes but i could
i could actually understand how the
audience is almost
sort of i don't want to say forced
character but the audience is following
forrest into this world
to research and i can understand a
little bit where if you're spending 20
minutes
on him dealing with his backstory and
like more on him that it might
take you you're almost like wanting to
get back to okay tell me more about
you know um yeah it's it's not
delineated in that way it's very
interwoven so like i said his backstory
with the particular woman at the club
they were talking about all the biggie
stuff there's a one scene which is like
uh
overflow of stuff but it really was less
about that it was just about it really
is as simple as this jaws analogy from
the perspective of
if you show who he was and is then you
have an opinion on that
if you don't you make your own opinion
and allowing people to make their own
opinion
it simplified the matter um i had also
had a scene where he went and
found dayton cali who plays you know
pool supervisor
and you show how he figured out how he
found russ poole
at a church so there was like background
in him digging and
you know when i got into the story like
the movie really begins
when him and him and johnny go head to
head and johnny says okay let me tell
you a story and we go
to you know um you know biggie's
you know murder that's really where the
movie begins that's at about
you know 10 to 12 minutes so the reality
of that is is like i had to get there in
the cut as fast as possible
and so showing how he found russ paul i
i even have like a little investigative
thing where he's in russ's building
talking to the janitor and
it just it just wasn't helping the
drive of the narrative and the story we
needed to get to the heart of it and get
moving very similar to like
the movie needs to get to david mack as
soon as possible because once you get to
mac it's moving you know it's just there
were real challenges in these things
that we had to
to balance i don't remember if the
version i saw
a few years ago if the beginning was
exactly what i saw yesterday did you
change anything
i took actually your your thoughts were
very impactful to me
and um i i made some adjustments to the
beginning there were
more things truthfully that i wanted to
do to the film that um
due to time and money and certain things
when saban and lionsgate acquired the
movie i was
unfortunately not given the opportunity
to do that i thought would have
really completed the circle for me but
actually i i have the utmost respect for
you steven
um to be frank uh i i
it always lived with me what you had
said so i made some changes in the
beginning there to address some of the
thoughts we had discussed actually
yeah because the beginning felt
different to me yesterday i'll be honest
i mean i saw it as you know i mean i
might have seen it three years ago now
you know i think you saw a three and a
half yeah it's hard
you know as you may know i i watch a lot
of movies
i know i know did the beginning play
better for you this time
yes it did and i think that well no it
did because i think that
if i remember correctly the version i
originally saw
it i was trying to connect how does this
all connect
yeah you know what i mean and how is it
all gonna go together and i
could be wrong about this but like was
the vo
of johnny at the beginning of the movie
saying was that like a little bit
different were you saying like there's
i didn't realize for eight days or this
was yeah there's some adjustments there
there's some adjustments in the editing
there's some adjustments in the opening
documentary
there's some adjustments with that stuff
collectively um but again
i got to be truthful there were some big
moves i wanted to do to this thing that
i didn't get a crack at but this is the
the political baseball filmmaking and
that's okay you know
well it's also listen you being blunt i
mean you were also dealt a
a very difficult pitch when you have so
many different people that are owners
or were owners of this film and it
constantly moving
and ultimately you know what i mean now
it's you know you're with a company that
obviously wants to
the good news is it's going into the
marketplace yeah that
i'm i'm happy to put this one behind me
i got to be honest i'm going to sleep
better at night with this movie out in
the world and behind me i i it's it's
the right thing for me but it's the
right thing for the world
um we fought for the truth and the
integrity of the messaging and uh
i'm proud of that i it's it's not it's
not by my standards a perfect film
and i don't that really should have no
bearing on whether you see it or don't
see it
to be frank because um people have
enjoyed other films i've made and i
don't think they're perfect films so
at the end of the day you know we live
and we learn i'm actually super excited
from a personal perspective because i
think my best work is actually ahead of
me
and i'm i'm i sort of i got paid to
learn
so uh i'm in my prime and i'm ready to
have my michael jordan years
uh i listen i think that the film does a
very good job
at pulling the curtain back on what
probably happened with you know
christopher wallace
and and if listen obviously we're never
going to exactly know
what happened but this you know no one
is um
uh i mean it shines a light on what
might have actually happened
you know and it and yeah it's a very
descriptive portrait
you know and doesn't you know what i
mean it gets in there
uh i mean that was our goal to just get
in there as deep as we could and and get
these
get the information out and let people
make their own choices and opinions and
belief and if people want to fight for
justice
um and and again it's bigger than
christopher we look at what's going on
in the world today with the trial and
all these different things that are
happening and uh you know we we can't
stand for less
we have to stand for something and um
this represents that
uh my last thing for you uh obviously
i'm a fan of your work as you know
uh what have you been writing working on
developing
what i've got some really super cool
stuff
stuff to me that i one thing in
particular i've worked on for a decade
which has come to completion which is my
baby
another thing that i wrote over the last
two years and
um i haven't shared this with anyone but
i will tell you
um and and only you i've been
writing uh to write and direct the
pistol pete maravich story
really yeah i have not told that to a
soul but i have so much love and
affection for you i
you are the first person to know this uh
that is it do you have
what do you do you have the rights like
how what what's
it's uh it's the it's steve nash is a
producer
um and peter lawson and uh
steve's obviously working in conjunction
with the nba obviously he's the coach to
brooklyn right now
and um a wonderful group of people and i
feel really honored i wrote my sixth
grade heroes paper
on pistol pete and i think this is not
for many who just hear it think it's a
basketball story but um
it's it it's it's a story of uh
generational trauma and psychology and
some really fascinating things so uh
you know i i usually take that answer
and i just politely say i'm working on
things and don't share but i
i i really appreciate the support you've
given me through my career and i meant
what i set up
i'm i'm very honored to be still
standing and i'm really honored to chat
with you when
when uh my publisher and i talked about
i said oh my god
i'd love to talk to steve i just think
he's a gem and
it's the your your cinephile nature your
love of movies your integrity
uh how you approach your craft is is so
important to filmmakers like myself
and um you know it's it's it's like
anything in life if you do it more and
more you learn and you get better
they don't teach you when you're
learning film about all the politics or
in making movies and the challenges that
go into final products when they go out
into the theater
um and you know my my name is synonymous
with certain work but i'm really excited
for what the future
has ahead and this is one of those
things and um
that's why i share i appreciate that
yeah the thing that's so funny
that i i think that it would be so
important
for everyone that writes about movies or
tv
to and it's never going to happen
because of the logistics but it would be
great if everyone could just spend
one day on a movie set or one day on a
tv set
to see actually how these things are
made sure
and the problems that come up and like
you know you
as a filmmaker you might have planned
for six months for this one day of
filming
and all of a sudden the location is cut
down to two hours
i got stories man my stories have
stories
i'll tell on this one and all of them i
i got a great book or documentary or
something in my future
yeah i mean but but that's the thing
that i i don't think enough people
realize
that like there's so many people who
just think like oh you know they had
this much time and blah blah blah but
like
they're not even thinking about you know
well the actor was really sick
and like he was throwing up all day just
getting him to do that one hour on
like a miracle you know well i i
appreciate your love and understanding
of filmmaker
uh filmmaking and and you're in a very
rare class
uh i i say thank you i listen i'll leave
you alone about pistol people
but [ __ ] i had more questions i don't
want to drill i'll just
let's just we'll leave it at that for
now that would be cool yeah no i but
that's something that could be very cool
let me actually let me ask you though
is it a movie or is it a series it's a
movie
okay i'll leave it there there's that
uh no man look i'm very happy this
movie's finally coming out for you
i wish you nothing but the best and i
hope you're making another movie again
very soon me too so